andrés se entrevistó a estudiantes de
primer y último año en su preparatoria
preguntándoles cuántas frutas comen cada
día los resultados se presentan en las
dos gráficas mostradas abajo el primer
enunciado que tenemos que completar es
el número promedio de frutas es mayor
para
mayor para y tenemos que decidir entre
estudiantes de primer y último año y
luego dice el promedio es una buena
medida para el centro de distribución de
y tenemos que elegir también entre
estudiantes de primer o último año
déjame ir a mi cuaderno de apuntes y
pensemos en esto pensemos primero en la
primera parte que solo calcular el
promedio para cada una de estas
distribuciones y te invito a que pausa
el vídeo y lo calcules por tu cuenta
así que primero pensemos en el número
promedio para los estudiantes de primer
año esencialmente solo vamos a tomar
cada uno de estos puntos de datos
sumarlos a todos y dividirlos entre el
número de puntos de datos que tenemos
tenemos un punto de datos en el 0
tenemos un punto de datos en cero así
que escribo 0
y luego tenemos dos puntos de datos en
uno por lo que podemos decir más dos por
uno y luego tenemos dos puntos de datos
en dos
y déjame escribo más 2 por 2 y luego
veamos tenemos bastantes datos tenemos 4
puntos de datos en 3 así que podemos
decir que tenemos cuatro veces tres
déjame círculo esto entonces tenemos
tenemos cuatro veces tres más cuatro
por tres y luego tenemos tenemos tres
cuatros así que más
por cuatro y luego tenemos un 5
más
5 y luego tenemos un
+ 6
y cuántos puntos tenemos en total
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
y cuidado de hecho tenemos 15 puntos no
he considerado a este déjame solo
tenemos 15 puntos y no me puedo olvidar
de este de aquí así que es más 19 + 19 y
cuánto será esto esto sólo será cero
este va a ser
2 este va a ser 4
este va a ser 12
esto va a ser otro 12 y luego tenemos 5
6 y 19 cuánto será esto dos más cuatro
más 24
30 más +11
41 más 19 nos da
60 60 dividido entre 15 34 por lo que el
promedio del número de frutas diarias de
los estudiantes de primer año es de 4
frutas diarias
así que esto de aquí es nuestro promedio
lo pondré en un color que resalte
y ahora hagamos el mismo cálculo para
los estudiantes de último año tenemos un
punto de datos donde no comen ninguna
fruta al día no son muy saludables luego
tenemos un 1 lo escribiré como + 1 luego
tenemos dos veces 2
qué es más 2
todos luego tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 veces 3 5
veces
+ 5 por 3 y luego tenemos tenemos tres
veces 4
+ 3
4 y luego tenemos 2
2 por 5 y luego tenemos un 6
+ 6 luego tenemos un 7 alguien come 7
frutas al día mucha fibra más
y ahora cuántos puntos de datos tenemos
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 16 puntos de datos así que
dividiré esto entre 16
cuánto será esto
esto es cero
esto es 4
esto es 15
esto es 12
esto es
entonces tenemos
45 + 15 es 2012 es 32
10 42 42 más 6 es 48 48 lo estoy
haciendo 42 más 63 48 más 748 7 55 lo
hice bien
déjame hacerlo una vez más
uno más 145 más 520 32 42 42 13 55 esto
es igualdad esto es igual a 55
entre 16 que es lo mismo que veamos eso
es lo mismo que
3 x 16
48 por lo que son
enteros y 7
16avos por lo que el promedio para los
estudiantes de último grado
el promedio para los estudiantes de
último grado
tres enteros siete dieciseisavos está
por déjame ver este estrés este es 47
dieciseisavos es un poco menos un poco
menos de la mitad está más o menos por
aquí por lo que el número promedio de
frutas es definitivamente mayor para los
estudiantes de primer año
tienen cuatro su número promedio de
frutas que comen diariamente es cuatro
contra tres enteros y siete
dieciseisavos el promedio es una buena
medida para el centro de distribución de
decidiendo entre estudiantes de primer
año o último año
el promedio es bastante sensible cuando
tienes datos muy separados de la moda
por ejemplo alguien de este grupo comió
19 frutas por día esa es una cantidad
enorme de fruta casi solo comer fruta
imagínate si fuera un dato más separado
alguien que coma 20 o 30 pedazos de
fruta solo un punto de datos va a elevar
el promedio eso no pasaría con la moda
porque la moda es el número medio aunque
alejarás este punto no cambiara el valor
del punto medio así que el promedio es
más sensible a estos datos separados a
estos puntos que están muy muy abajo o
muy muy arriba y ya que los estudiantes
de último grado no parecen tener datos
separados como esos yo diría que el
promedio es una buena medida para el
centro de distribución de los
estudiantes de último grado o una mejor
medida para el centro de distribución de
los estudiantes de último grado
así que seleccionemos ambas respuestas
por lo que el número promedio de frutas
es mayor para los estudiantes de primer
grado y el promedio es una buena medida
para el centro de distribución para
para los estudiantes de último año y de
hecho se puede ver aquí vimos que el
promedio para los estudiantes de primer
año es 4 pero si solo ignoras a esta
persona de acá y solo ves la
distribución de esto 4 no parece ser el
centro su centro parece ser 3 y lo que
pasa es que esta persona que come 19
frutas al día aumenta el promedio
mientras que aquí los 3 y 7
dieciseisavos realmente parecen
acercarse a la distribución actual
cercano y debo decir en ambos casos se
calculó el promedio de la distribución
actual pero aquí como no hay datos muy
separados de la moda el promedio parece
acercarse más solo diré a la mitad a la
mitad de esta pila de datos de aquí
así que comprobemos nuestra respuesta
la tenemos bien